plastiktüten sind in uganda längst
verboten doch in den vororten von
kampala liegen sie noch über mal
er will das ändern
andrew nokia ist 21 jahre alt
schon vor fünf jahren hat er seine
eigene firma gegründet
mit 15 kollegen stellte papiertüten her
der jungunternehmer kommt aus einfachen
verhältnissen für sein startkapital
sorgte er selbst ich habe erst
plastikflaschen gesammelt ich habe meine
kollegin der schule gefragt und wir
haben über 70 kilo gesammelt und haben
sie zum recyceln gebracht als die leute
gesehen haben was ich da mache haben sie
gedacht ich werfe holt geworden aber ich
wusste was ich tue
mit 12 dollar startkapital ging es los
inzwischen verkauft juli paperback in
ganz anders die kunden supermärkte
kleine läden oder apotheken
der markt entwickelte sich schnell
inzwischen produziert andrew pro jahr
20.000 papiertüten pro woche per hand
die einfachsten tüten sind in neuen
arbeitsschritten gefaltet die
kompliziertesten brauchen 32 angriffe
maschinen kann sich mit pro jahr nicht
leisten das papier kaufte er in kenia
die jungen männer haben sich alles
selber beigebracht
ich habe mir youtube videos angeschaut
wie die menschen in indien papiertüten
selber herstellen so habe ich das
gelernt dann habe ich einen prototyp
gemacht und habe ihn in supermärkten und
den läden hier gezeigt und dann waren
sie interessiert und haben mehr aufträge
gegeben wenn er nicht in der firma ist
studiert andrew poje an der universität
in kampala wirtschaftswissenschaften
hier sucht er auch nach neuen kollegen
für seine firma das land habe potenzial
für junge unternehmer wie ihn das
unternehmertums etwas ganz neues in
uganda
ich denke wir gewöhnen uns langsam daran
na klar es ist nicht ganz einfach zu
studieren und gleichzeitig ein
unternehmen aufzubauen
aber er hat es gewagt und damit
inzwischen viele preise gewonnen
seine pläne sind ziemlich ambitioniert
ich möchte der größte papiertüten
hersteller weltweit werden
ich möchte daran arbeiten meiner firma
zu erweitern so könnte ich noch viel
mehr herstellen die dann weltweit
verkaufen
ich mache das schritt für schritt und
ich glaube daran dass ich es schaffen
könnte den markt in uganda jedenfalls
gibt es viele supermärkte und läden
haben noch keine papiertüten eingeführt
juli paperbacks kommt mit der produktion
kaum hinterher und andrew poje
verhandelt schon der student will
maschinen aus dem ausland zur
papiertüten hersteller kaufen wenn er
den erhofften kredit bekommt